good morning John I really admire your
dedication to trying to get a bunch of
nerds to like sports that's a lot to
take on and I'll be honest for a long
time I felt like maybe you were trying a
little too hard and like it wasn't gonna
happen but somehow hitting me with ASU
Wimbledon news every week even when the
news has been very bad has started to
get to me I guess I'm on this journey
with you now and you've been on a bunch
of Journeys with me as well so thanks
for that and I'd like to maybe take you
on another one so far in this video I've
just been showing you a bunch of quite
boring things mostly like parts of trees
but I'm gonna bust out my handy jewelers
loop here which is designed to inspect
jewelry but can help you inspect pretty
much anything and see that each of these
trees and rocks are actually studied
with a bizarre crusting of life you
probably first heard the word symbiosis
when you were in fourth or fifth grade
but no one had ever heard it until 1877
when Albert Bernard Frank decided we
needed a word for something that at that
time May many people did not believe
even existed now when people started to
look at Lincoln under the microscope it
looked mostly like a bunch of algae and
this wasn't really a mystery people
weren't thinking what is like it they
were looking at like it and thinking
that is like a moss or a fern or a grass
or a tree it's just another kind of
plant but in the 1860s like 10 years
before Alfred Bernard Frank coined the
term symbiosis Swiss botanist Simon
schwendener looked at lichen and he saw
among the algae pretty transparent
structures that were to him pretty
transparently fungus Parts he started to
tell people about this and people did
not agree we as humans argued for a very
long time about this because this was
the first organism that did not appear
to be only itself neither the fungus nor
the algae could live apart but together
they became something that was neither
fungus nor algae this is kind of normal
for us today but like the explosion of
information that came with the invention
of the microscope shattered so many of
our understandings of our world and of
life on it they weren't just something
else they were an entirely new kind of
organism a whole new way of existing and
now we understand that so many things
including our own bodies exist
symbiotically all while that word itself
is less than 150 years old we are
surrounded by infant knowledge that we
think has been around forever most days
when I walk down a path in the forest
I'm barely even looking at the trees I'm
mostly thinking about work or worrying
about the planet or the people on it or
just singing a song in my head but
sometimes you look at the trees and
sometimes you look deeper and now we can
dive into what is invisible to our eyes
what a time to be whatever it is we are
and to get to observe our world on every
one of those trees is a whole little
world that the moment we polished glass
carefully enough we realized broke so
many of the rules we thought we knew
it's always there but for so long
totally invisible to us just doing what
works because that's what works John
I'll see you on Tuesday also we just
released an episode of Journey to the
microcosmos about lichen that inspired
this episode if you want to go deeper on
the history and beauty of lichens it's
there waiting for you and in the
description also if you want to start on
your own Journey we have worked with our
master of microscope to create the
perfect starter microscope which starts
at 350 dollars and it's available at
microcosmos.store where there's also a
bunch of other cool stuff